I do want to mention this Sports
Illustrated so I've had this for a
couple of days it says the Intrigue
surrounding the Jets quarterback
position following Aaron Rodgers week
one injury quickly picked up steam Aaron
Rodgers of course if you don't follow
football he left the Packers and went
over to the Jets
at the age of I don't know well I think
it's 38 or 39 now went over to the Jets
and it's getting a lot of hype in the
off season uh Rogers is going to
revitalize his career uh finally the
Jets are going to be relevant you know
for the first time in 600 years maybe
the Jets will uh have a chance at a
Super Bowl and then Aaron Rodgers runs
out of the tunnel and uh for the first
series on offense on Sunday and within
about 75 seconds he's torn his Achilles
isn't out for he's out for the season uh
which is I mean it's it's terrible
um
but in a very in a very dark way there's
a certain humor to it because this is
just the Jets if you know anything about
football
the Jets really are cursed
and uh it it it's exactly what
we all kind of expense it's shocking but
also exactly what you expect
and it's also why I could when they
announced that Aaron Rodgers was going
to the Jets
I could it's like of all why would you
do that of all the places you could go
when you're Aaron Rodgers there's got
there have to be other options
including just going to the golf course
and retiring you can do that too
you can go to the Jets that always ends
in tragedy for everyone
every person who's ever gone to the Jets
it ends in tragedy why would you do it
that's exactly what happened here so
anyway he went down with the injury he's
gone for the season
um
and continue with uh Sports illustrator
while we know Zach Wilson is the team's
starting quarterback and there won't be
any form of competition there's plenty
of debate over the backup job things
like an interesting Twist on Tuesday
when it was reported that former 49ers
quarterback Colin Kaepernick had entered
his name into the conversation according
to NFL reporter Jordan Schultz who said
he spoke with Kaepernick directly the
authority of 35 year old's agent reached
out to the Jets about an NFL return
following the injury to Rogers
um
said I just spoke with Colin Kaepernick
who tells me his agent has reached out
to the Jets about his desire to make an
NFL return Kaepernick remains on the
west coast working out uh about 24 hours
later the Jets made it clear that
they're not interested in Colin
Kaepernick
um now
anytime you get a story like this about
Cat every single year it's the same
thing it's been a tradition now going on
seven years that a starting quarterback
goes down with an injury and then
there's all the speculation oh maybe
they'll call Colin Kaepernick
um and the first thing you always have
to point out is that Colin Kaepernick is
the guy infamously in his Netflix
special
who who said that NFL owners are are
like plantation owners
and being on an NFL Squad being a
starting quarterback for an NFL team and
making millions of dollars plus Millions
more with endorsement deals is like
slavery it's just like being a Slave
it's just like being forced to pick
cotton in the fields in the in the 1840s
exactly the same you said
and yet
somehow this guy is eager to get back on
the plantation he wants to be owned
again he wants to be enslaved again very
interesting thing
are you one of the millions of American
men and women dealing with premature
hair thinning and hair loss or maybe
you're scared about inheriting that
thinning look because it runs in the
family well finally there's a real
solution that delivers on its promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals and unpleasant spells provia
Hair Care uses a safe natural ingredient
called procapital to effectively Target
the three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss probio supports
healthy scalp circulation and delivers
nourishing ingredients to strengthen
hair follicles and anchor them to your
scalp Previa guarantees more hair on
your head than in the shower drain
probably as effective for men and women
of any age and safe on color treated and
styled hair provio Works guaranteed are
100 of your money back it's that easy
right now new customers save over 50
percent off provia's introductory
package at proviahair.com see results
for yourself right now don't wait that's
probiette hair.com slash
but I also love
I love this tradition of the Colin
Kaepernick speculation because
it always shows the people who know
football and the people who don't
um and so this time around it was people
like Jamil Hill she's always in the in
the mix
who's out there pushing for the Jets to
to pick up Colin Kaepernick
and putting everything else aside about
Kaepernick right like
if you know if you have even basic
football knowledge
you know that there's just zero 35 years
old
he hasn't played football in seven years
and he was already on he was already
past his prime when he left the NFL
he was on the bench he got kicked out of
his uh his starting job for for Blaine
Gabbert
before he left
and now he's been gone for seven years
making uh shoe commercials
and you think he can come back at 35.
and uh and succeed in the NFL will just
kind of shows shows us what your uh the
extent of your football knowledge I
suppose if you'd like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed